Jeff Deverett, Film Producer, Entrepreneur,
Writer, Director: Say, whoa, time out. You're
making a five million dollar feature but it's
not financed and you don't have distribution? So
how are you making the five
million dollar feature again?
Film Courage: Does having a higher
budget let's say over $500,000
guarantee that your movie is probably
going to be of a higher caliber story wise?
Jeff: If you're a good producer slash
director like a good producer director
team who knows how to deploy their
resources you know very very effectively
then I would say the more you have to spend the
better quality your movie is likely going to be
as long as you're not wasting it like
if you're putting it on screen you know
like if you let's say I'll give you an example
okay let's say you have a $500,000 movie right and
then you get an extra $50,000 if you go and hire
like a fancy caterer who's going to do the meals
yeah will your crew and cast feel a little bit
better sure they will but will it make your
movie better probably not but if you spend that
fifty thousand dollars potentially on one scene
where it's a big production you know a bigger
location with more extras or something like that
then it'll make your movie better so that's what
I mean by deploying the resources effectively
so if you're you always have to be careful
with your resources no matter what you have
so people think at 250 I have to be more careful
than at 500 no you have to be careful of both
levels and at 750 just deploy them as best you can
so that you put most of it on screen so that your
movie looks better so obviously the more you have
to spend if you're deploying it wisely you have a
better chance at making a higher quality looking
movie you know potentially more production value
now obviously it's going to always end up there's
there's elements that doesn't matter how much you
spend acting all right now you could say the
more I spend on actors the better actors I'm
going to get I don't personally believe that
I believe that there's good actors at every
price range and hopefully you get good
performances out of them all right so you could
say you know I'll get a better cinematographer
if I spend more money you'll definitely get
a more experienced cinematographer because you
know they have that's why they're charging more
because they've done more and you know chances are
it's more predictable but it doesn't mean a brand
new cinematographer can't you know shoot a great
movie I mean there's young upcoming people who are
really talented who just need a break so hopefully
you get one of those you know and directors and
all this kind of stuff hopefully it all gels and
and so I that's where you the magic can happen
at low budgets where everything gels and you just
get great performances great directing sometimes
you know experience does matter and you don't make
the rookie errors because you've done it before
and that's why spending more money on people
who know what they're doing is a little bit
more predictable but it doesn't mean that people
who haven't done it before can't do it well but
you know to get back to your question yeah if you
had an extra 250 and you put most of it on screen
your movie's gonna look better it's just gonna
look bigger and and you know hopefully like
when I say on screen you're using more extras
your costumes are better your production value
is better by the way if the story's bad the
acting's bad you could spend 5 million and
still come up with a bad movie I mean you know a
bad movie is going to be a bad movie so it does
start with a decent story a decent vision from
the director and good performances and then the
rest is just capturing it properly you know focus
sounds the shots you choose that kind of stuff
earlier you said the audience doesn't care what
you paid for your movie I know film festival
audiences might care though because they just want
to know what was your budget range and how can I
emulate what you did kind of everybody lies I go
to tons of festivals I sit in these screenings
and they say well how much was your budget oh
I'm going to tell you the truth and then they
they usually triple it or quadruple it nobody
wants to say they made a $10,000 movie because it
feels too small right so how do you know what's
real unless you've done the accounting for it
i've been there done that I know what things cost
I know you know now when a filmmaker says to me
hey I didn't pay anybody then I say great you know
you're lucky that you got people to work for free
I don't do the movies that way I believe they
should get paid but I'm not saying it's wrong you
know sometimes people say oh I spent five years
making my movie because I just shot on weekends
or this or that type of thing I say okay fine but
you know I'll gain it's not my business model i'd
rather shoot in 20 days consecutively get it done
release it do the next thing so everyone's got a
sort of a different business model and a different
vision of what that could be but when I say people
don't care about how much they spend people like
to discuss it they like to throw numbers around
they like to because you know they want a point
of reference for themselves to see you know can I
make a movie how much does it really cost so there
are people who are curious especially at festivals
you know who want to sort of know because maybe
they're thinking of making their own movies so
they're doing that as a point of reference but if
you've watched a movie and you've left the theater
and you said wow that's a great movie and then
somebody said to you oh that costs fifty thousand
or five million you'd be way more impressed
if it was fifty thousand wouldn't it be way
more because all of a sudden this great movie this
epic movie was made for fifty thousand dollars and
the surprise would be on the low end as opposed
to the high end so I always joke and I say if
I were to ever win an academy award in my speech
I'm gonna say what the actual budget was because
it's gonna be so much lower than what anybody
expected it to be you know because everybody
expects if it's a good movie that it has to cost
all so much money and by the way here's the other
problem with the narrative that indie filming
everybody throws around Hollywood style numbers oh
I'm making you know I told you before I get phone
calls I'm making a five million dollar feature and
and it's all ready but I just need you know
finance and distribution I say whoa time out
you're you're making a five million dollar
feature but it's not finance and you don't
have distribution so how are you making the 5
million feature again like in your mind you're
making a 5 million dollar feature but in reality
what you're probably going to spend is $50,000
I mean that's what's really going to happen if you
want this feature made unless you are connected to
some really high net worth individuals who
are prepared to make big donations to you
so everybody still throws around the big numbers
especially in the Hollywood circles and everybody
wants to pretend holly and at festivals you
know it's Hollywood talk right which is you
know well 2.5 I made my movie for you know 3.2 and
blah blah blah and it's like all right whatever
doesn't look like you did so you know
it's different strokes for different folks
what does it cost to get bankable stars in
your movie so bankable stories you mean a-list
talent basically people who can who people say
who's in it and when you say the name they say
oh I know that person that's a bankable star all
right so that's what I call bankable because there
are sort of secondary bankable words oh i've
heard of that person as opposed to oh you know
when someone goes to see a movie in the theater
the first question they asked is who's in it and
you know that's why a-list actors make so much
money because people say oh if they're in it I'll
go see the movie right they don't say what's the
movie about they generally say who's in it even
for animated films they say that's the crazy part
like I mean you're talking voice a talent you know
so what does it cost it's flexible
but a-list talent cost more than
it then indie film producers can afford and the
other thing is that chances are a-list talent
doesn't want to do indie films unless it's their
story or they're personally connected and they
want to direct and the reason is is because an
a-list actor does not want to be associated with
a c-list film like the production value is too
low and it's going to taint their reputation
I say unless it's their story and they're
or they're very connected to the filmmaker
or whatever and they want to help share that
vision so I'm gonna say that you know a-list
talent you know is in the seven-figure range
like you know the million-dollar plus range
b b or say a minus list or b plus you
know is going to be high six figures
and you know when you're making a movie for a
half a million dollars or even a million dollars
and you want an a-list actor then your budget
just doubled you're gonna have a two million
dollar movie now a lot of people will say I mean
all the distributors who are watching this will
say it's worth it because that's what's
going to sell the movie and they're right
it is worth it if you know for sure you got a
sale on the movie see if you go that route and
you don't get your sale you've just doubled your
budget you've taken a huge risk and maybe it's not
going to work but some people say it's a better
risk to put an a-list actor in and spend that
money it's less of a risk than it is to not have
that a lot of international distributors will say
to you don't even bother making a movie unless you
have recognizable bankable talent which I don't
totally disagree with but you know the genre I
work in family I don't really use any recognizable
talent because I think it's more about the story
than it is about the actor now it recognizable
talent wouldn't hurt but I don't think the numbers
would justify in terms of the selling side the
cost of the actor now there's some people that use
previous a-list actors who maybe now have become
you know I don't know what their rating would be
but then there's a draw in that too that someone
that had been out of the limelight for a while
hadn't been working for whatever the reason is
and now has made a comeback and they
may be totally different persona wise
appearance wise than they once were and then
that's probably a draw as well very very big
draw that's very very common you know I call them
a minus or b plus list actors people who are not
you know in the limelight you know they're not the
top 50 or whatever in Hollywood but they're still
they've done they've been there done that and
are very recognizable very good for international
sales because people still recognize their face
or their name so that's much more common and and
it is bankable also but it's not cheap you
know a b-list actor could be fifty thousand
dollars a day not uncommon to see that at all
and they're worth it you know first of all
they're good actors right so you pretty well can
depend on them giving a good performance usually
and yeah they have that that sale ability or what
you call the bankability and you don't know for
sure how bankable it is but you're pretty certain
it's better to have them not than not to have them
but it's just a finance equation right so like if
you were to say to me why don't you put you know
like two b-list actors into lead roles in your
movie and I'm going to say because it'll double
the you know be half a million dollars in that
fee and I don't think I'm gonna I think I'll only
increase my sales by say $350,000. So I'm doing
some calculations beforehand and saying it's not
feasible for me to do that but if I did it the
other way and said you know by putting a $500,000
actor in I could get you know a million
dollars of extra sales of course I would do it.